hey everyone
uh so we'll start the live stream uh the
actual presentation in one minute or so
so more people join uh
but anyways
hi nice to meet you i'm omar and zak is
here with me he will also be presented
hey everyone
how are you today
oh doing good it is it feels like a
monday even though it's thursday
okay wow it's been a week how are you
over
yeah i'm doing good and in the day today
was one of those days in which i spent
quite a bit of time
debugging weird issues
in my code but yeah so
they went quite quickly
good yeah and still dealing with one of
those right now with the hub so always
fun
yeah
all right what do you think that we get
this started sure sounds great
all right so before kicking this off
let me explain what we are going to do
today
so the idea is to show you what you can
do with the hawking face hub we'll kick
it off with like very basic things and
as we progress through this session
we'll show like very
advanced
like power user use cases
which can be quite interesting to you
if you don't know me hi everyone i'm
omar i'm a machine learning engineer
at cooking phase i don't know would you
like to enter yourself
absolutely uh my name is zach mueller i
am also a machine learning engineer at
hugging face i just started around
november so i've only been here for a
few months
but uh most of my work has been on the
hugging facehub the little api library
awesome so yeah so i guess we can get
this started so at the beginning i will
present a bit then zach will continue
the presentation and then i will present
you
more things
all right
so
if you don't know cooking face like the
hooking face hub it's a platform through
which people can share
and collaborate with ml models data sets
and demos as well so we'll get this just
started
and this is how things look when you
login into your account
what i want to show first before any of
this is models i think modus is probably
the most important thing
so quick cooking phase has right now as
you can see 20
28 000 models almost uh maybe by
tomorrow there will be 28 000 models
and you can find models for many
different things so here at the left you
can see that there are tasks such as
a question answering for example a text
classification and you can click here
that plus 13 and you'll see that this is
not only for nlp for natural language
processing but also for things such as
audio or computer vision and even like a
structural data classification so
tabular data
so here you can see like
all of the models by sorted by most
downloads so
let's go directly to this first one
which is gpt2 so gpd2 is actually like a
quite famous model uh
it's for generation
and what you see here at the left is a
what we call model car so model guard is
this concept that was proposed by
mitchell and
so there were like a couple of
researchers in this idea
and it's pretty much a way of document
documenting what the model does so for
example in this case
it says
like what what the model does it
explains
some high-level description and
something that is quite important is the
intended uses and limitations and there
are even like explanations on how to use
this model and there's like this
limitation on biases
and it's quite flexible actually so you
can even add like a
explanation on how the model was trained
how it was evaluated and things like
that
by the way feel free to ask any question
in the chat we'll have a minute to
answer questions at the end
sorry for the scrolling
so what's quite interesting is that here
on the right you have like this widget
so you can try out the model directly in
the browser yes for example with this
input my name is mariama my favorite
and what you get then is
some text generated by the model by by
the gpd2 model so my favorite character
is here
it's just generated text and you can try
this out
with your own
input
so for example here there's another
generated output which is nice
and something that is cool about the hub
is that everything is based in git based
repositories uh what that means is that
you get files and versions control
and you can see like the history of this
repository so here you can see like all
of the commits made here
so if you you've used github before the
workflow is quite similar so you can git
clone
the repositories work locally and then
do the github git commit get push
you can even do things such as branches
merge so it's the same kind of workflow
with the difference that here we have
the management of large files so in ml
many models can be like quite big so
here for example we have half gigabyte
models a half gigabyte files and there
are repos with quite a bit more of data
so that's a bit harder to handle like in
normal git workflow so here we use gtlfs
you don't need to worry that much about
it but pretty much we're able to handle
like large files
here
which by the way like all of this is
completely free
so
maybe let's go and create a repo just to
show you what you can do so i will
create i'm clicking here in my profile
picture i click new model
i'm sure you can create any model you
want so i will call it press 123
you can specify a license so i will pick
this one
and the repo can be either public or
private so it's whatever you prefer
we have unlimited repos in both so let
me create this one
so at the beginning you don't get
anything
of course
which makes sense except the license and
maybe what makes sense to show you first
is the settings so settings is actually
quite self-explanatory what you can do
is change the visibility of the repo so
you can make it public or private
you can transfer so if you need to
rename it or if you want to transfer
this report to an organization which
we'll talk a bit more
in some minutes from now you can do that
and finally you can delete the
repository if that's something you want
to do
maybe let's go to
the model card so previously i showed
you a model card but at the end a model
card is just a markdown file
so for example here i can create some
stuff
this is a
model card
so the model card is just markdown so
when you go back
here is the the content
and as you can see here at the top you
get this
that is a link
which you can use to filter
for all models that have that specific
license in this case this is a license
filter and that's specified here at the
top in the metadata
so at the top what you can do is add
some
configuration that is specified like
some of the metadata so for example if
you want to add some tags i can hear a
this is an english
this is a text classification
and this is you know
avert model things like this
so i just committed this will show in
the history
and here at the top you can already see
that
this was a label as text classification
a
en for english and birth so when you go
here
what you can see is that actually at the
right now you already have this widget
which is actually quite nice
because by specifying the
this type the text classification type
you automatically get the widget
maybe let's go back to the gpt2 just to
show you what we have over there so bpp2
actually has a bunch of different
filters so for example if you want to
filter for tensorflow or for pytorch
or for text generation or english you
can click any of this
and let's see how these are specified so
let's go to the readme and that's the
nice thing about everything being open
source that you can just go and directly
check out like the
check out like the filters or the tags
that people are using
so here you can see that they specified
a language
attack
expert tag and the license which is mit
so where do
these other tags come from for example
tensorflow or expert
so we actually automatically based on
the file extensions can uh
can find quite a bit of things so for
example
if it's a df model h5 file we
automatically detect that as a
tensorflow model or pytorch model or
directly in the config for transformers
we can detect that this model type is
gpt2 so we try to make this as easy as
possible and automatic for you but in
the case that you have like
you want to specify some different
things or some additional tags you can
always do that
so for example what i realize now is
that here in the readme
the language was not specified with
attack it was like with a separate
argument in the game file so we can go
back to the repo i was working on which
is this one
and here what i did before was wrong
like i just put it in the text which is
not the right way to do it you can do it
like this
and here we go like now we do have like
a language that you can use to filter
so let's go and explore a bit what
filtering is so for example let's say
that i want to see all of the text
classification models including phase
you can see that there are like 2 000
okay 2800 models for text classification
and here i can even write a sentiment
and i now i find that there are like 216
models that have sentiment so it's
probably like
sentiment analysis
models
but as i was sharing before this is not
limited to nlp so for example if i want
to check out like some i don't know text
to speech so text to speeches you
receive text it generates a speech
you can find a 160 models
which again these are open source and
you can try it out directly here in the
widgets so for example here i wrote
hello this is a test run and here it
generates an audio that you can play
you cannot hear it but
you get a you get idea
and again this is not limited just by
task so for example let's say that i
want to find a
model for spanish
so we have now 428 spanish models
and let's say that i am interested in
translation so now i see that there are
218 models
many of them by the helsinki nlp group
which are for translating either from
spanish to another language or from
another language to spanish
by the way in the case that you would
like to learn more about how to create
like good model cards
i would suggest you to check the course
so in the course a huge face course
which is free again so you can go there
by clicking
[Music]
this
burger icon and here in community course
we have a section
focused completely in which are like
good practices for good modern cards so
it suggests you like some of the
sections that you should add
with some examples of
good model cards some notes on the
metadata
and yeah
uh
one last thing i wanted to show you
related to
the basic usage of model repos
is that you cannot you cannot upload
tensorboard traces and this it doesn't
matter if you are working in any library
if you upload to any repo like
tensorboard process
you get automatic uh free hosting of
tensorboard
so for example this is for big science
which is a research project at hooking
face and they upload here deluxe for
tensorboard so it automatically gives
you like this stack which is training
metrics
it takes a bit because in this case the
i if i recall correctly they have a lot
a lot of logs
so we need to wait a bit but it will
automatically generate this free
tensorboard hosting
which is quite cool
all right uh let me quickly check if
there are any questions and it seems
there are no questions so
let me show you like a couple of quick
last things uh
so let me go back to the model i was
working on
which was this one
and let's say that it was automatically
detected as a
task that was not the one i was
intending to
so what you can do
is overwrite any automatic decision so
even if we try to do things
automatically sometimes we can get
things wrong so you can overwrite
anything that we do by select by writing
here python type
and i can put here like text
classification for example
which i wrote
correctly it should happen like this
and then you overwrite any automatic
thing
but maybe you then realize that here we
automatically suggest like some a
default example
and you as a user like maybe like your
model is like a for very specific kind
of input and you want to
specify like
some examples default examples
so this is an example and pretty much
what i do is a in the value a you can
specify a title and a text an input
let's say
for every example that you want so here
i added two examples one that says my
name is amar in spanish and another one
that says another test
so when you commit this
here at the top right so you already get
one of these
but here at top right you can click
examples and you can see that it says
example one and test which were the two
tests that we were working on before
this is even not limited just to
text so for example this one is a
let me check if this is a good example
this one is a
a speech example and here they have like
an audio a file as an example so let's
just go and see how they do it so we can
go to the
rhythmic and they do like something
extremely similar right so they put
example title common boy sample one and
here is the source so here is the link
to this
exact
exact sample
maybe one other thing that is cool is
that
at home in phase we have like this uh
use in transformers for example so if
you're in gpt2
or in the helsinki you have like this
using transformers which you can click
and it gives you like a code snippet
that you can just copy and go directly
and test it out in a codelab notebook
and it also gives you like a snippet to
clone this repo and work locally and if
it has this link read model
documentation that takes you to the
documentation of that concrete demo
all right
let me see if there was anything else i
wanted to show you about this
i
yeah okay so one last thing i will
show you related to models is how to do
filtering for libraries
so
many people know about transformers at
hog in face but something that many
people don't know is that we actually
have
use cases for third-party libraries so
we build collaborations with other
libraries such as
spaces sentence transformers speech
brain stable baseline stream for
reinforcement learning first
and you can filter for this or you can
go to spacey
you can go here for example for this
a english
example from spacey you can click
compute and you get like direct
inference here and you can even click
here using spacey and you get a widget
of how to use this model specifically
in that library which is actually quite
nice
and if you see you see here at the
bottom right
you get like some evaluation results
this is a
this is a way in which people like users
can self-report metrics
on their model
which is also added in the metadata so
here in the readme the model card you
can find like these metrics which are
self-reported
and we actually already add these
metrics automatically when you choose
the hog and phase transformer trainer
but you can also use this for other
libraries
and actually here at the
bottom left you can filter
to get all of the models that have these
evil results
let's go for this one
and here
we have again like the evaluation
results
but what is quite cool is that we get
this view leaderboard link
which is a an integration with papers
with code
so here you get all of the models that
were evaluated on this same data set and
you get like this nice leaderboard and
you can click any of this so for example
let's go to this one and it will take me
back to hawking face to the repo that
had this concrete self-reported metric
yeah
and yeah just to finalize this maybe
like one thing that is cool as well is
that
if you use edge maker you can click here
train and you guys like this
easy way in which you can find your
models
or train models or deploy them if you
want to play them
and
we also have like the inference api and
it pretty much allows you to do like
basic http requests
that you can make any like
calls so it can be javascript python or
code like whatever library language you
want to use
to make inference so this same thing
like same thing as in the widgets you
can make http requests and test out
or integrate those very easily with your
product so if it's a android app for
example or if it's a more complex thing
you can also do that
all right
that's everything i wanted to talk about
models let me just give like a two
minute overview of datasets but datasets
have pretty much the same story so we
have data sets which are also git based
repositories
and you can do similar things such as
filtering by language
by task by categories
even by size or by license
if you click on that set you also get
like something similar to a model card
which is called a dataset card
and you can even explore the dataset a
bit in the browser so for example here
you get like some examples of this
dataset
and here at the top right you get like
this used in dataset library which gives
you a constant input in how to use this
with the open source datasets library
at the at the right you can see like
which models were trained with this mod
with this data set sorry which is quite
cool so you get like a
models linked with datasets linked with
spaces which we'll talk a bit later
and let's go just to this model just to
see
what this means on here for example this
model was trying our fine tune
with glue and multi nli
and how this is detected is again
everything goes to the metadata so in
the metadata models users can specify
which are the two datasets that were
used
all right uh i think that was everything
i wanted to talk about models
eh let me bring back zak
hey there we go okay
yeah
so i don't know if you would like to
present them
sure yeah we can do that
let me go ahead and share my screen
sure
perfect
so yell at me if for some reason it
doesn't look good but i think i can see
it so uh piggybacking off of what omar
just presented
we're now going to look at the hugging
face hub library which is a python
interface for you to do everything you
just showed you without having to go to
the website instead you can just do it
in your python interface be it jupiter
or whatever
uh so this is the hugging facehub
library uh you just do pip install
hugging facehub
and then uh we're gonna import a few
helpful classes from the hugging face on
the hugging face api
the model filter and the model search
arguments since so far we've just looked
at models
uh now let's propose a few situations i
want to be able to find a text
classification model
that was trained on the glute data set
and
i'm working high torch so i wanted to
work in pi torch as well
how would we frame this
uh before we do anything we need to make
sure we can communicate with the api
so we're going to instantiate this
hugging face api class here and i'll
zoom in a little bit so folks can see a
little better
and uh next i won't be able to know what
i can search by so we're going to create
a model ours that's going to be our
model search argument
now these model search arguments will go
through
all of the models that we have that are
shown publicly and will give us
everything we can search for in a nice
exploratory fashion so if i just look at
model arts here we can see that it'll
tell me we have
these available attributes or keys that
we can search for author data set
language library and so forth
so the first one we want to look at was
text classification right
well pipeline tag is uh what we
basically call tasks in this case so if
i go over to pipeline tag
and i press tab
it'll give me autocomplete
and what we find is there's text
classification right there
and what this will basically do now is
if i say hit enter
we'll get this helpful little string
back that says text classification this
is what the api knows to read
whereas this fancy nested object
is a nice way for you to go and search
through what's valid without having to
memorize every little thing
so let's continue on and you'll see why
this uh quickly becomes useful the next
one we wanted was training on uh it's
trained on the glue data set so we'll do
model args
dot data set
would make the most sense
and then we'll look for glue
and there it is
now if we look at it we have this
special data set colon
glue so here we get to a case where it's
not really one to one which you'd expect
when i'm say about to go search the hub
and give it a query
and that's really why the model search
arguments are very
powerful and useful for you because even
if you just want to know what to search
for you don't have to sit there and
struggle for hours instead you just go
and explore this nested dictionary
object to go and find it
now the last thing we wanted was it
needs to be compatible with pi torch
so we do model art
and then
if we look we have this library
attribute
and then this goes through all those
third-party libraries that omar talked
about earlier
right at the top for me is pytorch
now that we have all of this how do i
say go and find
our model
so we take all this and combine it
into the list models function which
we'll go through and query all of our
hosted models and find anything that
matches
so we're going to say i want a filter
that uses
this pipeline tag
filter equals
we wanted to use our data set that we
had
and finally we wanted to use the pytorch
library
and now when i hit enter
we get back a bunch of different models
like i think over a hundred
posted on the hugging face web
that match our requirements so here we
have this first one it's the xlm roberta
large uh it mni model and so now without
having to necessarily leave my workspace
i can go through and find
a particular model for the task i'm
trying to do
so let's see how complicated we can get
with this though
let's propose a new one where i want to
be able to find all uh token tagging or
ner models that are for the french
language that are compatible with both
pi torch and tensorflow
so similar to before we're going to
write a model filter
and here we're it's going to look a
little differently so we'll say
we're going to use the mouth filter
class sorry
which the model filter
basically lets us write
uh our
rest api call like all this fancy uh
stuff we had in parentheses here but
wraps it in such a way that complex
queries are easy to read and perform
so for example i'll do model filter
language i'll set that to model
rs.language
and then we want french and since we're
using the two uh
two letter acronyms that'll be fr
and then the task in our case is token
classification
so we'll do model arts pipeline tag
token classification
eventually
there we go
and then finally we want to be able to
say i want to use two libraries so i'll
say library
equals
and then i'll put a little uh
parenthesis around it and we'll say
modelarbs.library.hi torch
and model rs.library.tensorflow
this now
takes that pretty complex query and
writes it in a clean and organized
fashion
also if you do know what all of these
are you don't have to use the model arbs
so for example i could rewrite our
library as library equals
pi torch
tensorflow
rather than this very long uh
basically
this very long chain uh but that's only
if you know what you're actually looking
for
all right now we have our model filter
let's search for the model so we'll do
api.list models
filter
we should find only about one or two
models now that fit our very specific
query
and so now with this
if you can't quite find the model you
want using the web interface you have
very specific requirements you can
instead use this functional api to go
and find
any particular model that you need
especially if it has very niche
requirements
so that is pretty much what i had for
the models so let's go see what we have
question wise are there
any awesome it doesn't look like there's
any
so
omar you can magically pop back on if
you would like
awesome
actually
i i won't talk more about data sets i
don't know if you would like to also
present about data sets though yeah
absolutely uh we can do the same thing
for data sets afterwards if you'd like
sure
sure that's good
right so let me present so i will talk a
bit about spaces now
so if you haven't heard about spaces is
pretty much a very nice way
in which people can create and host ml
demos
so for example if you want to build your
portfolio if you want to collaborate or
if you need to show cases to
stakeholders it's like a very nice tool
to create the most
that you can show to other people
and what we support is a open source
libraries such as streamlead and gradio
but nowadays we also support a static
spaces which would be like html and
javascript
like or even like bokeh or tensorflow.js
and more like custom even like i don't
know fast api or flask kind of use cases
uh there are actually like
this is
extremely updated it says 200 spaces
nowadays we have around 2000 spaces and
it's pretty cool like you can explore
these
demos created by the community so for
example here
this demo again everything is open
source it takes about a minute so this
one will be like a good example for now
or actually it took six seconds
but this is like an example for
denoising so what it does is that it
removes the noise of the image at the
left
and it's nice because you can go file
some versions and again like see all of
the history
again like this is open source we
try to highlight like some cool demos
created every week but you can just go
out there and explore
uh
over 2000 demos by the community
what might make sense now is actually to
create a space just to show you like
what's the usual workflow so you can go
here click new space let me use the
test demo
again you can specify a license
and you can specify the required sdk you
want so i will go with radio right now
but you can use any of this
you can again with public or private
and here when you begin you'll get this
link to documentation
and you get like some instructions on
how to do it so what it's suggesting is
to git clone this repository create a
app by file with this content and then
again do github git commit git push it
even has like some additional tips but
you can also do all of this directly in
the browser so first i will just copy
this code and i will explain it in a few
minutes
but what the tutorial said was to just
create a app
not by fine
let's paste this
at the beginning it says it's building
actually we can click here c locks
and in the logs you can see like what's
happening
back there so it's ever like one of your
spaces breaks this is like a very easy
way to debug what's going on
so now it's running we can go here
the first time it always takes a bit
longer because it's the first time it's
being set up
so okay let's look at the lock so it
seems now it's running and here we can
write something and here we go
so this is a radio space it's very nice
because you get like a very nice inputs
outputs interface
so you can get here like very nice
titles descriptions links to
to the paper to the github repo with the
original code you can take screenshots
and let's go to the actual code
so this was like a very uh
non-ml case this was just like a hello
world example
but what created us is that you usually
have like a interface
which has a function that processes an
input which in this case was a text
input and outputs another thing which is
output of that function which in this
case again it's text
let me show you like maybe a more
interesting example i'm just copy
pasting right now from another place
and this is using transformers but again
you can just like any library that you
want to use so if you are a tensorflow
user you can use this
what you can do is uh
with the pipeline
class here i'm loading a translation
model from helsinki which is an english
to spanish one
here i have like a processing function
don't worry about what's in there pretty
much the idea is that it takes an input
it does some processing and it has an
output
and finally there's the interface so it
has specifically what's the function
which is the input which is the output
which is the title and some examples
even
so let me click
commit changes and what will happen in
few seconds it's still building is that
it will fail
or respect it will fail
so we got runtime error
so it's complaining that we don't have
transformers in here
and that's because
as a user you can specify whatever
libraries you want
and you can do this with
a file called requirements
and for example here i might want to
have
let's say transformers
sentence piece and
torch i think these are like the three
letters that we want
but when every time you commit it will
automatically kick off like a rebuild of
the entire system which is quite nice
okay and in this case since it needs to
pip install all of this the first time
it will take quite a bit so here you can
track in the logs like
how the process is going so right now
it's downloading some files from the hub
so it's already downloading the model
and here we go so just with those like
10 lines of code
we got this interactive demo which has
like a nice title
here you can click like the examples
you can click submit
here you have the output and you can
take a screenshot that
will automatically be downloaded and you
can share social media if that's
something you want to do
something that is very cool is that here
at the top right you get this link which
says linked models
so when you click here
you actually automatically we detect
which is the model that is linked to
this space so i can click it
and here i'm back to this
and here again like you'll get a list of
all of the spaces that are using this so
for example here there is a space
that we are working on so we are back
here
something that might be interesting for
some of you is that you might want to
use a very bad model or you might want
to be you might want to make some calls
to some
server or some api and you don't want to
expose
your password or your tokens so you can
go to settings and we have this thing
which are called secrets
and idea is quite straightforward you
can create here like
let me put a letter name so token for
example
you can put like any value
you can click add
and now they see there is like this
this ripple secret that you can access
from the code as an environment variable
in the case of credio
which is quite nice because now you can
access like things without exposing
those to the users
so if you want to use an api if you need
to make any calls to a custom server you
can use this
if your space is ever broken you can
also like restart the space
but apart from that like all of the
other settings are pretty much the same
as models
or yeah as models
uh
one other thing and that might be
interesting for people that are using
the hogging face hub brick which is what
zac was showing you before
is that you might want to use it
with private models or you might want to
so he showed you how to filter models
but you can also create repositories and
upload files
and if you want to do that you need to
have a token
so here you can go to settings
and you can go to access tokens
and what is very nice is that you can
create a user access tokens so for
example if i click here new token
it can be a read or a great token
so let's say i want a right token and
this will be for block
you can generate a token which you can
copy or you can refresh if you want and
you can use that directly
outside hog in face to make calls to
your models that are
your models that are in hog in place and
it's very nice that you can create mini
tokens because then if
one of them are exposed you don't need
to change all of them so the good
practice is to have like one token for
each use case so if you have a blog and
a server and also
so
a github actions workflow that syncs
your github repo with your space you can
have like one token for each of this
which is quite nice
one last thing i would like to show you
is organizations
so you can go here and click new
organization
and i will create an organization called
llamas
which might be vacant i don't know
just like it's not
so it's a an organization
and something that i like quite a bit is
so at point as the pack so our
organization is pretty much a group of
people uh so you can have like
organization models and data sets and
spaces so let me go for example to
kerato yeah so
clearly is this organization
in which a group of people from the
community are creating keras examples
models
and datasets so this is like a very nice
community collaboration
so going back to the settings you can do
a bunch of stuff also adding a logo a
website you can add members and you can
even give like different
roles so write read or admin different
members
you can have billing api tokens and
different kind of stuff
and something i like quite a quite a bit
is that you can specify a or domain name
so for example if you are using this in
your research group or in your company
you might all of you might have an email
which is i don't know something like
this right on face
so this for example is my domain name
but for your company you might have like
a
company
so you might want to
automatically add people or offered this
option
to automatically join the organization
so actually what is very nice is that if
you
if you specify this domain name and you
configure this when other people with
the same email sign in they will get
like some notch to join this
so you will get something like this and
here you will automatically get like
this option saying like hey we suggest
you to ask to join this organization
and that's like a very nice way because
if you're a research group and you do
have like 100 people and you don't want
to
you want like a very easy
straightforward way for people to join
this is like a nice way which is also
secure
and it's a good way to collaborate in
your company or research group
all right uh
i think that's it from my site let me
bring zak back again to show you more
cool stuff about the holding phase hub
sure yeah we can take a look at some fun
things
so um
i'll go ahead and share my screen then
there we go
all right so uh similar to how we could
search models
right with that functional api we can
also do something similar for any sort
of data sets that we might want
so for example let's propose another
little uh situation where
i'm interested in trying to find models
that uh
pretty much can be used with the raft
benchmark
um and specifically and data sets that
uh are valid within the sort of
benchmark
and what we can do is by using the
functional api
we can go through and search for any of
those data sets
now very similar
to
the
model search arguments and model filled
from earlier
we have the data set search arguments
and the data set filter
that operate exactly the same way so
we'll make some data set args
and similarly to before
we get this sort of exploratory process
with cap completion
that tells us what all we can search for
now the first thing um that i wanted to
look for and actually i'm going to
partially change that this is a typo
this should be
superb data set
is i want to look for the benchmark
right that superb benchmark that we're
doing now uh so we have benchmark as an
available key so if we do benchmark
and then
i look there's superb
super b data set
and here's another case where
knowing uh what these data set search
arguments is really important
because here we have this special
benchmark colon and then our
superb data set
uh and the next uh requirement that we
want is we want the one specifically by
loot uh luton
so uh if we look down here at dataset
parts again
we find author
and then we can look for
linton
there it is
now here because author isn't
necessarily a part of the regular api
call we're just going to go ahead and
directly use the data set filter
so i'm going to say filter equals data
set filter
benchmark
equals our data set arts benchmark
superb
and then our author is data set art
author
now if i
list our data set similarly to our
models
we'll find the two data sets that so far
support that query which in our case i'm
more interested in this one than the
predictions test
now let's try and get a bit more complex
with this
i want to find all data sets that
contain both english and french whose
annotations were crowdsourced and my
task is say
conditional text generation
that's a very specific
very
niche
query that we're trying to do so let's
see if we can find that
so here i'll use the database filter
again
and rather than using the search
argument i'm going to go ahead and just
use the raw strings here because
we've sort of already talked about what
most of these look like
so i'm going to say languages
and we're going to say the two letter
characters for each of the languages so
we're going to say french
and english
now we're going to say language creators
and i want this to be crowd sourced
this is just the raw string as we would
expect it to be and then the past
categories
we want to be conditional text
generation
that basically is one to one what we
asked earlier
so now if i do api and list data sets
and look at the first result
make sure i spelled that right
have to be crowd sourced here we go
you can see that we find the
opus parce uh data set by a gem
and this fits everything we wanted the
annotations are expert generated as well
as machine generated
there's a few other
tags in there but it's also
um here we go we have our languages off
to the right here
as well as the
somewhere all the way back here should
be the task categories
so with this functional api you can very
quickly go and find uh you know any sort
of data set that you might want to train
on uh that you potentially would want to
just start and play with a model uh for
instance rather than necessarily having
a task where you know exactly what you
want to do you can use this to go
explore
what can i train to
say fit this particular criteria
that is the functional searching api for
data science
all right thanks a lot
so i think we're pretty much done there
were like a one last thing we would like
to show you is this activity feed so
it's pretty much like a place where you
can see like the changes you've been
doing as a user and at the right you can
see like what's trending out there so if
you want to see like which models are
being like quite a bit lately or data
sets or spaces
and you want just write them out you can
go here you can else play give them a
like
if you like them of course
and yeah that's pretty much everything
we wanted to show you
please feel free to ask us any questions
in the chat we'll
we can answer questions although i think
that we only have one
let's go to the only question so the
question right now is from jonathan
is
if i want to use the model such as cpt2
or d5 and employ it to a onnx
or some kind of model file does the hub
tells the size of the model and the
required cpu memory size
uh no we don't at the moment we might
have this in the future uh it's also a
bit complicated because it's dependent
on what framework you are using right so
if you go to gpt2
here you can really see like a
tensorflow model uh weighs 475 megabytes
by but the pythorac model weights 523
and then cpu memory size yeah it's a bit
more complicated
something you can also do by the way
since we are having like more of an x
models is we have a filter for this and
expect this to
increase in the future
and here you can know like
which repos on the hub already have one
of these files
and yeah
all right
since we don't have any other questions
so i think we can wrap it up for today
what do you think zak yep that sounds
like a plan thank you guys so much for
joining us today uh it was a lot of fun
and i hope you learned a few things
about
uh hugging face the model api the data
set api and spaces
maybe one one question that people might
have is like what's
when well when would they like to use
like this hog in facehub programmatic
api instead of using like the browser
sure yeah um personally it's a
preference idea in my head uh usually
if there's some very complex search
argument you want such as you know what
i showed earlier it's a lot easier to do
with the functional api rather than the
website for right now
the other case would be you just want to
keep everything in your workspace and
you don't want to have to jump between
tabs you can just have everything there
and don't necessarily mess with your
flow
in my opinion it's pretty much what
you're comfortable with we give you
these options so that way whatever is
the most efficient for you uh you can
absolutely just go and have at it
uh but i would not necessarily say one
is better than the other they each have
their benefits and their uh complexities
are in their limitations there we go
thanks a lot yeah so in case anyone is
interested in this like this is open
source
so you can go just here to coin face hub
please leave a star
just to add a bit to sucks answer
we also have like integrations with
third libraries so if you go to
in our documentation we have its page
which says
like which are the different libraries
that we have integrated and these are
completely based on this library
so if you need like programmatic
creation or access to repositories
using the coding phase hub a library is
like quite powerful way to do it
but if you don't want to use even python
like all of our endpoints are
open and documented for you to do for
you to use so if you want to integrate
this to some other kind of service you
can also do it if you
want to go a bit more hardcore way
all right
okay yeah i think we can repeat that now
perfect thanks a lot everyone for
joining thanks a lot zak for joining as
well and have a great day
have a good day everyone
see you